all right was the Trump CNN Town Hall
the most corrosive television event in
political history depends who you ask
for example a republican Congressman
Byron Donalds was actually
reinvigorated into continuing to not
answer the simple question did Trump win
in 2020 or did he lose Trump setting the
tone during the town hall that he's
insisting he won Byron Donald's asked
about it he will not acknowledge nearly
three years later that Trump simply lost
that day this is one of the reasons why
these events are so corrosive listen to
this
how are the facts you do acknowledge
Donald Trump lost the 2020 election
correct again we're going to continue to
talk about 22.
let me tell you
are frankly kind of tired of y'all
bringing this up inflation border you
don't have the courage to express your
Americans
I'm a republican voter voters want to
talk about inflation the Border fentanyl
the debt ceiling foreign policy if you
want to talk about the 2020 election
let's talk about this we do know that
Mark Elias was in many jurisdictions
suing to actually change election
procedures which by the way is at the
hands of the state legislature in every
state according to the Constitution not
in the hands of Courts not in the hands
of the Supreme Court the state
legislature we do know that to be a fact
we do know that true you won't State
your opinion about actually factually
what happened in the 2020. you guys want
me to make a state and this is like
Frank let me tell you right now this is
not a trick question they act like it's
a trick question it's just okay fine you
want Trump to have won you want him to
win in 2024 you think Biden's bad but
can we just start with Biden did win can
we start there they refuse Joe
Scarborough from MSNBC this this morning
had actually a pretty good take about
the impact of this town hall
no surprises and yet
it was just it was a disgraceful uh
performance yes
um I'm I'm constantly telling people not
to catastrophize over Trump that he's
actually going to lose there's a former
Republican member of Congress by the way
because he keeps drilling down deeper
and deeper into his base
um but it is it is uh I I can't believe
I'm I'm going to use
catastrophizing language here uh but it
was it was just it was disgraceful on
every level yeah
it showed uh I wouldn't say it's
dangerous for democracy because we
passed that a long time ago
but it showed the corrosive effects of
trumpism over eight years
and I've got to say
I I the most shocking part was an
audience
who cheered on a president who tried to
overturn
American democracy yeah Joe Scarborough
is completely right now a practical
question becomes did Trump convince
anybody one way or the other uh we'll
get to Van Jones's take on what it did
to Democrats but they actually had a
focus group on CNN with a group of trump
supporters and you may or may not be
interested to hear that it didn't affect
any of them one way or the other Trump's
spending that time just lying and lying
and lying it just had no impact one way
or the other vote but that's what they
have in common that most of them are
Trump supporters what I want to ask you
first of all is do you think show of
hands anybody think Donald Trump looks
better after this town hall no hands and
if you think he looks worse
No Hands maybe you think the same thing
about him as you did when you walked in
so on Trump supporters it had no impact
whatsoever what about on Democrats well
van Jones says
if you watch this and you're a Democrat
you're probably feeling a lot better
about Joe Biden all of a sudden I think
if if you're a Democrat watching that
you think we've been criticizing and
complaining about Biden
this is a horror show that we don't want
a rerun of and I think a lot of
Democrats were appalled by his behavior
him throwing Ukraine under the bus you
know I hope he gets sued again this
morning for libel and and slander and
everything else he's been getting so
horrible uh you know toward the people
who have been on the other side of his
legal cases but you know I think that
we've got to be careful here now because
uh Trump has a particular trick that he
uses with Nostalgia uh the whole make
America great again is about there was
this era that was wonderful it was 1950
which we've talked about before so
listen I I think the best case scenario
as atrocious and disgusting as the event
was uh on the merits the hope is
Trump supporters still support him
other Republicans were maybe appalled
and of course Democrats may be appalled
enough that now they are more interested
in coming out to vote in in 2024 against
Trump if he is indeed the nominee it's
still a while to go but let's hope
that's the outcome
plastic it's everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year here's something super
simple you can do to reduce plastic and
help the planet a little bit our sponsor
hold on bags is the company making
plastic free trash bags and zip seal
kitchen bags they're just as strong and
high quality as the plastic bags you're
used to hold on bags are 100 percent
plant-based and home compostable meaning
they break down in just weeks not
decades their zip seal kitchen bags come
in sandwich or gallon size to fit all of
your needs whether it's carrots or
crayons at home I put all of my food
waste in a hold on trash bag throw it in
the compost pile and when I throw a hold
on trash bag in my dumpster I love
knowing it's not filling our landfills
and oceans with plastic single use
Plastics harm the planet at every Stage
production disposal decomposition join
the growing movement away from
single-use plastic these products are
really great it's so easy to make the
switch go to hold on bags.com
Pacman and you'll get 20 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below